taking Ukrainian children from places
like marry upole deporting them to
Russia was a war crime approved at the
very top says the international criminal
court some would appear later in
propaganda stunts in Moscow Russia says
it was saving these children from a war
zone if that's the case says the icc's
prosecutor why not give them back I
would call upon the Russian Federation
not only to repatriate and reunite
children with their mother country
contact the United Nations Russian
Federation can contact the icrc contact
the third country and say well we have
no ulterior motive we just want the
welfare of the children to be first and
they can go back to Ukraine and safe
places that's as likely to happen as
Vladimir Putin ending up in The Hague
for now he's shown his contempt for the
arrest warrant issued in His Name by
appearing to visit Mary upoll over the
weekend
40 Nations met in London to show
solidarity with efforts to investigate
war crimes in Ukraine its prosecutor
General condemned Putin's visit to
occupied Ukraine we've seen them now
indicted alleged war criminal Vladimir
Putin his response is to go to marry
upole and wander around and be filmed
there what did you think when you saw
those pictures of him in occupied
Ukraine you know that ukrainians they
they really don't uh treat this
seriously they I think they also they
all suppose that he as a criminal he
returned to the crime scene as many
criminals do
the police did come for Vladimir Putin
today to listen to not arrest him but
outside of Russia there are multiple
plans afoot to bring him to Justice
Ukraine and some legal experts are
calling for a special tribunal to be set
up to investigate war crimes in Ukraine
like those established for Yugoslavia
Rwanda and other conflicts hoping that
will put even greater pressure on
Vladimir Putin and the Russian
leadership for now the Russian president
seems unfazed by the prospects of
prosecution but efforts will continue to
build the case against him Dominic
wagorn Sky News